[Music]
people love the show so much they love
your character and I have to say you get
the crossbow you know I look at all the
characters on that show you get to have
the crossbow which makes you the coolest
character in my opinion yeah because
vodka yes yeah you and chewbacca I mean
but you cannot if you're holding a
crossbow anything you're doing is cool
you don't I mean yeah you could be
putting on lipstick still cool
it's yeah you know I remember the first
season they gave me the motorcycle as
well you know I was like I got a poncho
a crossbow and a motorcycle I was riding
it in the you know in the first season
I'm trying to look cool on it and this
little bit of fat right here Wow I mean
yeah it's got to be but you know it
can't be easy because the conditions
that you guys shoot in it's like 100
degrees it's humid and those crossbows
are heavy aren't they it's super heavy
yeah I mean it's the best weight loss
weight loss program on the planet being
in Georgia and the humidity and the
weather but um yeah I've become pretty
good with the crossbow elem every year
so my son has a bunch of crossbows up on
his wall back in New York which i think
is a felony of my how old is your son
he's 14 though okay all right almost
crossbow age yeah yeah have you ever
found that like because you're really
using a crossbow and I would I know me
if I was in between takes I'd be playing
around with it you must be getting
pretty good I'm pretty good with it yeah
I'm pretty good with all the weapons I
mean John Sanders our weapons expert he
makes us very familiar with him but yeah
I took my son paintballing it was right
before Comic Con last year mm-hmm and I
sort of had an unfair advantage it was
like one dad and me and you know his
group and my group were all I ball on
each other and then the guy who ran the
paintballing place had a Boondock Saints
paintball gun which had me and Flannery
you know on the
but his gun went like you know and all
the other guns were like pop pop pop pop
so I just he gave you the good one yeah
and I just shredded all the kids I mean
like little kids like you know cowering
on the ground I think you know limping
away you know having a fun paintball
game and suddenly it's the guy from
walking dead Boondock Saints yeah you're
hitting them with the stock of the gun I
went Rambo and all those kids that
must've been fun your fans are as you
could see when you come out here people
are so enthusiastic which is a nice
thing but it does it ever get a little
borderline where you know they're giving
you crazy gifts there they're there
you don't I mean where it feels like
it's getting a little shady yeah I mean
I had I had one girl there's a big
audience full of people and one girl
raised her hand and I just called her up
and she walked up with this little like
a clear bag that had meat in it with
like you this yellow oil and I go what's
that he she goes it's squirrel
what and she goes excuse ya I hunted it
down with the shovel and the first thing
that catches her gift to you yeah I mean
the first thing I thought was wow like
you're pretty fast congratulations
that's amazing
I had I had one girl send me a breast
implant which was kind of fun and she
also hunted down with a shovel
wait wait what she gave you a breast
implant is erotic er I don't know what
that is what I mean she said she read in
an interview I said in the press so she
sent me her breast implant but um
yeah yes without all that'll do I use it
I use it as my phone cradle in my
trailer and enjoy the day all right
yeah it's my little phone sits on top of
it oh and you're so again you just put
it oh I see yeah yeah it's kind of fun
it's good that you made use of it yeah